the argument that there needs to be more
regulation with these institution is
frankly ludicrous if you look at how
they're regulated before
one of the reasons in fact the primary
reason we have this dodd-frank rule is
that many people felt there had to be a
response to the 2008 financial crisis
the government put forward a study on
the financial crisis there were disputed
results in the study but one of the
interesting facts of dodd-frank is the
study on what caused the crisis was
released after the law was created I
think what the law really was was a
political response to many political
objectives and not to the financial
crisis and therefore it will probably
fail to ameliorate any future crisis to
come the most evident thing that emerges
from dodd-frank is that two components
of government policy involved Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac the two big agencies
that are involved in mortgages in United
States and neither of those are
addressed in dodd-frank so if you were
going to say that housing had something
to do with the crisis and there are two
government entities that had a huge
amount to do with the crisis at the very
least the law could do would be to
address those entities and in fact
they're left out glass-steagall was a
law that was created in the 1930s did a
very interesting thing it tried to
segregate risk it tried to take much of
the risky assets and put it in one form
of financial institution and then it
tried to take the rest the safer assets
and put it in banks much of
glass-steagall had already fallen apart
by the time it was formally repealed and
it was destroyed because of monetary and
fiscal policy in the 60s so you see that
when you put in these very very
restrictive rules however
well-intentioned they are they require a
lot of things to operate successfully
and I don't think any of the people in
the 1960s who were involved in Great
Society programs we're really thinking
about the consequences on Bank law when
they enacted the kind of programs they
did but in fact they did enact those
programs inflation did increase bank
structure was compromised laws were put
in place to ameliorate that and you did
come up with the kind of hodgepodge
system that was finally formally
dispensed with in the late 1990s but by
the time glass-steagall was eliminated
banks were involved in almost all the
risky activities that would lead to the
explosive activities of the 2007 and
eight and two
tonight many people have argued that
finance needed more regulation that's
just frankly untrue the fact is the
financial institutions of America were
supervised prior to the crisis by any
number of entities the fact is they did
a terrible job and the fact that as many
of those institutions have been given
more authority in the aftermath of the
crisis and there's no evidence that they
knew how to do the job they were doing
beforehand so the argument that there
needs to be more regulation with these
institution is frankly ludicrous if you
look at how they're regulated before I
think there's growing understanding of
how terrible this law really is the
single most indicted read on dodd-frank
is to read dodd-frank itself I'm going
to say it will either be overtly
repealed or secondly it will be
effectively repealed it will be
effectively repealed because the rules
that will be created under dodd-frank
will be so arcane will be so difficult
will be so tangled will become such a
maze of bizarre provisions that their
effect will not be any law that is
really dodd-frank that whatever you
think dodd-frank will be about it will
not be about in reality and therefore it
will be effectively repealed the problem
with the debate on dodd-frank now is
people take broad topics like there are
provisions in dodd-frank called consumer
protection and they sound quite sanguine
when you say consumer protection it's
just two words but if you read the
consumer protection provisions you
realize it has very little to do with
consumer protection and all sorts of
things to do with other sorts of
interests that will not help anyone so I
hope it becomes a nuanced political
debate where politicians actually look
at provisions and they put in front of
the American public all the bizarre
things that are happening in this loan
law I think if people saw those bizarre
provisions then the law would be killed
and that would be merciful for not only
America but for the world